christian mccaffrey panthers running
back who returned to the lineup seven
weeks after suffering a high ankle
sprain against the buccaneers in week
two he'll be on pftpm
tomorrow he is day to day for the
carolina panthers according to head
coach matt rule there was a report
earlier today that mccaffrey may miss
some time with a shorter injury and
shereen here's what was going on
yesterday as i was in the extended nbc
viewing room the distant nbc viewing
room with the
the
connection that allows me to hear
everything that guys like chris sims uh
may be saying
chris noticed the play when mccaffrey
got injured on a hit near the sideline
and then i started watching christian
mccaffrey carefully and you could tell
he had discomfort that he was messing
with his shoulder pads and moving his
his arm around and after the game there
wasn't much information and i went
through some of the usual channels to
try to get some info and i kept getting
zero and it was one of those
circumstances where it's not just the
usual situation where they were ignoring
me
they were deliberately being quiet about
it so something's going on with that
shoulder mccaffrey is going to want to
keep playing after missing so much time
due to the ankle the question is
is it a pain situation is he at risk of
further injury what's really going on
there
but day to day to me implies you're
gonna let this guy play if he really
wants to
could he miss time it just all depends
on whether and to what extent it hampers
his ability to play at the highest
possible level but it's definitely
something to keep an eye on
yeah mike i think you texted about the
same time i texted and we were noticing
the same thing with his shoulder it was
very obvious that that he was in a great
deal of pain and went out of the game
and he tried to come back for one where
he did come back for one play but he
immediately went out of the game and you
could just really tell that it was
bothering him so
it probably hopefully is just going to
be a pain tolerance thing where he can
play with it not in danger of making it
any worse i tell you what though mike i
watched that whole game i had that game
and he just makes such a huge difference
for that offense there are very few
backs in the nfl that you say they make
a difference normally you i'm along with
mds that you can throw any back in there
and your team's gonna be okay but there
are a handful of special backs you know
the derek henry's and the dalvin cooks
the way he's playing and christian
mccaffrey is one of those guys and he
just makes such a huge difference
especially in the red zone when you look
at what they did in the red zone they
were four for four on touchdowns
yesterday they're eight for nine on the
season when they have christian
mccaffrey and they're 10 for 21 and
scoring touchdowns in the red zone when
they don't have him he's just a huge
part of that offense and they really
need him out there if he can play and
you know he's going to want to play if
he can but you also think about his
future and you don't want it to do
anything that would that would need
surgery or further uh injure it so you
want to make sure he's okay but if it's
just a pain tolerance thing i guarantee
he's going to be out there
yeah i i agree with you and
look it's one thing for us to say pain
tolerance any time a coach says it i
think you're maybe putting your guy out
there a little bit because then it's on
him if he doesn't play hopefully words
like that won't be used hopefully we're
just characterizing what the situation
is and mccaffrey if it is pain tolerance
i guarantee you he will play because he
got the big contract as did other
running backs the other running backs
are earning their contracts he probably
hasn't felt like he's earned his yet and
that is going to drive him to do
whatever he has to do to play i'm
surprised they were able to keep him out
of the lineup for seven weeks with the
ankle injury i don't think he's going to
want to stand down especially as he
feels
the opportunities for the panthers to be
relevant and competitive this year
slipping away they're now three and six
you don't have many more losses you can
take at this stage of the season and
still be alive for a wild card in a very
competitive conference where
right now the rams hanging on to the
seventh spot at five and three so the
panthers need him and they need to start
winning and one of the teams they
will be facing next the team they will
be facing next we'll talk about them in
a minute the tampa bay buccaneers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports